bonjour et bienvenue sur des gones à la
leçon dernière émission concernant la
sicilienne d'âge d'or donc j'ai pour
cette émission j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir stéphane leroux laborde
bonjour stéphane un jour et loi je
regardais encore une fois le générique
ce superbe note du berger qu'on
recommande aux débutants quand même oui
tout à fait un tout à fait maths du
berger qui donc est une arme très
efficace puisque ça permet une date et
en quatre coups seulement donc c'est
quand même extrêmement rapide enfin là
nous allons parler aujourd'hui de la
défense nash d'or ce système avec 6 g
iii donc un système avec g3 stéphane ça
implique que l'adversaire donc le joueur
qui a les blancs puisque nous nous
jouons la défense nador figuig et noir
jouent solide a priori pas forcément
pour gagner
ouais je sais quelque chose très solide
il a essayé d'imposer un étonnant à roxy
avec ses 4 notamment ça arrive ça arrive
et c'est bon c'est quelque chose de pas
très très dangereux puisque le fou est
caché derrière son pion le pian 2 4
donc c'est une variante qui est plutôt
défensif du côté blanc exactement donc
tout de suite pour commencer cette
analyse de ces sienne lorsque nous
allons mettre la position la position
donc pour l'instant la position de
départ on va vous détailler les premiers
coups et donc on verra comment les
blancs peuvent tenter des choses
après j'ai 3 comment bien réagir du côté
noir puisque c'est notre souci principal
bien comprendre la cécilienne d'âge d'or
avec les noirs donc tout de suite eu
quatre vous vous avez les noirs vous
jouer c'est simple la cécilienne tout ça
stéphane on l'a déjà commenté de
nombreuses fois qu'elles vivent trois
encaissés 6 des quatre pions prend des
quatre kelly prend des 4 c'est un homme
de coups un peu différent dame ces sept
on voit que ça retransmise dans la
position qui essaient 3e 6 g iii à 6 fou
j'ai deux cavaliers m6 petit rock des
six
voilà donc la position on y arrive par
un autre ordre de coups qu'on verra tout
à l'heure on reconnaît notre nash dorff
avec cette fameuse formation de pions on
a sorti de caliance et 6 et le canadien
m6 on a mis la d'avancé 7 également on
reviendra sur lot de coups dans la
partie suivante puisque là c'est un
autre ordre de coûts qui a été choisie
par les deux joueurs et on voit que les
blancs ont mis leurs fous en g2 alors
comme tu dit stéphane premier remarque
c'est que le fou est bloqué par son
propre piège voilà la seule
il faut faire attention du côté noir
c'est la poussée e45 qui peut être
dangereuse étant donné que le tour à 8
pour l'instant est sous le feu du fou g2
donc on le verra régulièrement dans
pratiquement toutes les variantes les
noirs ont des problèmes pour jouer les
plans avec des seins qui voit là puisque
justement des cinq sur une faute
les cinq sur une faute puisqu'il ya eu
cinq attaques le kapsys attaque
également encaissé 6 et en plus ils à
tours habite derrière donc c'est
hautement problématique de jouer avec b5
dans cette position c'est aux blancs de
jouer donc ça c'est la position de base
1 vraiment la pression de base que vous
obtiendrez à chaque fois que votre
adversaire joue rage et trois premières
tentatives des blancs c'est un coup
d'abord curieux c'est le coup cavaliers
ce2 alors stéphane on se dit pourquoi on
l'avait l'idée c'est que le purin 4 et
protégé maintenant par le fou donc ce
cavalier peuvent être être bouger ce qui
est fait est l'idée des blancs c'est de
proposer au noir le fameux et audemars
auxi avec le coup ces deux c4 qui
empêche peut-être pas définitivement
même pour un bon moment là les pouces et
libératrice des six des cinq exactement
donc décidé 5 tout de suite
c'est légèrement optimiste puisqu'il
peut y avoir des fouets f4 attaque la
dame a éduqué prend ses six
éventuellement le pion au cap qui
avançons au 5
on n'a pas envie de le jouer tout de
suite des cinq et on ne pourra pas jouer
après donc il faut se préparer
psychologiquement à être enfermés
enfermé par le pion ces deux on sait car
une erreur tout de suite on va voir le
une robe possible ce serait dur usb 5
voilà pour l'instant je sais c'est 4
tout à fait et là on voit que le fou
j'ai deux se réveille puisque le
cavalier c6 est potentiellement en l'air
ainsi que la tour à 8
donc ici on jour et vraisemblablement
cavaliers français si ce qu'elle est
processes peut-être d'un procès s'il a
sûrement le 5e 5 obligeant cavaliers des
cinq forcé qui est des cinq forcé mais
ça c'est pas du tout un plaisir pour les
noirs en jouer cavalier f4 peut-être
sûrement cette position il ya beaucoup
d'options il y avait les d4 qui
intéresse encaissé 3 qui est très
intéressant kadhafi 4 aussi de toute
façon on va prendre en d5 et la
structure des tons noir et très affaibli
le roi stéphane est toujours au centre
alors on sait que la position de roi
c'est comme un facteur très important
dans l'évaluation de la collection donc
ici ce n'est tout simplement pas
possible
après qu'est et ce2 on ne peut pas jouer
17 mai 5 à cause du fujian donc ça c'est
une des premières idées des blancs et
juke et les ce2 ils veulent tous les
quatre
l'inconvénient pour les blancs stéphane
c'est bien entendu que ça perd beaucoup
de temps et perd du temps le cabinet a
bougé deux fois et puis le faut savoir
que les taux de maroussi cécile bon cfi
casse pour empêcher des 5 mai les pions
blancs vont se retrouver eux-mêmes figé
en fait exactement quand pour lutter
contre les taux de mariage si on vous
propose une partie modèle c'est la
partie donc madoff entre mathieu love
each qui a été joué évidemment en
yougoslavie avec des noms pareils c'est
évident qu'il faut cette c4 petit rock
donc pour l'instant rien de bien
particulier
question pour les blancs qu'est ce
qu'ils font dans cette position bon ils
peuvent pas vraiment je me fous aux
trois puisque ça permettrait aux noirs
de jouer qui est léger ktk valliot 5
avec des gains de temps à ta clope sur
ces quatre attaques le faux 3 donc le
développement de ce fou c'est un est
déjà pas si évident ils choisissent donc
de jouer b3 voilà pour mettre le fond de
baie de ski et la case naturel dans
l'étau de marantz si pour les blancs qui
est une case possible le pion b3 défend
plus le pion ces cadres nient tout ça
c'est très avantageux et maintenant se
pose vraiment la question pour les noirs
comment sortir ces pièces stéphane voilà
bombay tandis qu'on peut pas jouer des
scènes que la case naturel du fou a
l'air d'être la case 17 exactement le
fou s'est vite
bon alors normalement on veut jouer b6
est fou 17 ça c'est un plan tout à fait
classique lasser mais là on ne peut pas
toujours le même problème s'ils ont des
cons bouche le tube et qu'elle prend ses
6 et de 5 et là tout de suite c'est
terminé mais là c'est pire que twitter
puisque même la caisse des cinq est
protégé par le pion donc sa perle à
tours ça perd tout de suite du matériel
on joue donc fou 17 normale m c'est un
coup qu'on joue comme ça four b2 et tour
assez vite
voilà c'est en enlever la tour du fou et
maintenant des 5 peut être à l'ordre du
jour
mais pas tout de suite puisque
maintenant le câble et des quatre
contrôle aussi la case des cinq mais
souvent peu joué deux des cinq avec
l'idée que quand les blancs prennent la
case c3 où ces deux est affaibli c'était
donc d'autant plus jouer cavalier
prendrait quatre tout de suite et
ensuite b5 voilà ça c'est possible
puisque le fou 17 contre le d5
donc en fait pour résumer dans l'étau de
la roxy qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
faire
eh bien vous avez envie de casser ceux
qui ont ces quatre de l'attaqué soit en
jouant des cinq fois champion d ici
c'est quand même toujours très délicat
soit on avance ses pions béquilles en
général beaucoup plus simple donc c'est
pour ça qu'on mêle fois en 17 ans mines
d'abord c4 avec des scènes pour ensuite
pour un jouet des cinq plus facilement
exactement
donc ici on met le fond 17 on menace de
choix qu'il prend des 4 et b5
donc ça c'est tout à fait normal on a
mis nos pièces au bon endroit
éventuellement la dame on pourrait la
remettre en b vite pour continuer à
aider à jouer des 5 et en plus libéré la
tour donc beaucoup davantage dans cette
position les blancs ont joué qui a et c
3 pour empêcher des singes pour empêcher
des cinq mutins calais ces trois
contrôles des cinq salles empêche pas
vraiment on aurait pu jouer qui les
prend des 4 et des saintes mais on peut
jouer aussi tous rêvent des huit coups
tout à fait classique à emmêler pia son
centre et après qu'avait laissé deux
dames des vies tout simplement avec une
très belle position menace b5 les blancs
jouent dame eu deux normales toujours
pour empêcher des 5 et là c'est là qu'il
ya le coup clé dans cette position c'est
le coût 15 cavaliers à 7
maintenant bessin qui est imparable
toutes les pièces noires donc se sont
mises à la protection de ce coup b5
les tours sont très bien placés pour une
ouverture de ligne le kayak si c'est pas
si mal placé toutes les pièces noires
sont au top
on va jouer b5 et ensuite la position
deviendra excellente pour les noirs
pourquoi parce que tout simplement les
bleus ont perdu trop de temps dans
l'ouverture mais après b5 comment pour
aminé avec des 4 le cavaly c3 qui devra
bouger et enlever une protection
ou à la casse des cinq exactement
exactement donc ça c'est ça fait partie
des idées ici vous avez un dynamisme
très fort cette position est bonne en
fait le plan à cavalier ces deux gros
neuvième round n'est pas très dangereux
on va tout de suite passé stéphane à une
autre possibilité pour les blancs
puisque y en a beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de plans de jeu différents c'est parti
avec la partie l'ati contre ifs kof
alors ils se coiffent on a peut-être le
remettre dans le contexte ça a été
pendant très longtemps le meilleur
joueur yougoslave
il est assez âgée aujourd'hui donc cette
partie date de 1969 quand il était au
top de sa forme et il comprenait
extrêmement bien la ccn major c'est donc
un joueur de rennes 2 4 6 5 des quatre
qui en prend des quatre cavaliers f3
petite astuce ouais ça change pas grand
chose d interposition on peut pas on
peut peut-être joué aux 5 5 5 alors
possible oui c'est un hospice de pions
en fait voilà c'est fait puisque sur
cavaliers prend il y aurait damas un
échec qui récupère les cavaliers qui
gagne qui veut dire qu'ils gagnent les
cavaliers donc eu 5 à l'art de gagner un
pion le 5 gagnants toujours mais je
crois qu'on joue avec ses 3 après tout
simplement on joue ça dans un esprit de
bangui et ça se passe très bien aussi ce
qui est prend des cadres donc là lors de
coups et toujours pas à l'ordre du jour
à 6 g 3g 3 le fameux cavalli m6 fou j'ai
2 donc si on joue dans l'ordre normal
dans sa position normale tuant des six
quelques l'aï s'il choisit de jouer qui
nécessite d'abord pour diverses raisons
mais ça c'est pas vraiment notre
problème petit roc dames ces sept cas et
ses trois des six et nous sommes dans la
position
ouais la voilà la position où on a vu
tout à l'heure cavalli co2 qui a été
tenté
ouais avec l'idée donc de jouer ces cas
depuis l'es3 puis four b2 qui perd trop
de temps comme on l'a vu ici nouveau
nouvelle tentative foudroie - fo 3 pas
mal à développer logique développe là
une pièce tranquille
peut-être les blancs là elles veulent
jouer avec f4 oui régulièrement fait ses
fans le plan des blancs cédric est
processit donc pions prend celle ci sera
conseillé hautement conseillé pour
éviter les veaux 5 et une fois qu'on
arrivera dans ces structures donc les
noirs auront trois pions e6 des six
essais 6 bien placé a priori bien placé
on jouera avec cavaliers à 4 pour
rentrer sur la case des six essais 4
avec une structure de pions complexe
c'est ce qu'on va voir ça c'est ça s'est
produit
dans la partie suivant les sept fous 17
donc là c'est un coût normal c'est à
dire qu en fait l'idée c'est que sur qui
les français si ce bon on va reprendre
du pied mais de toute façon
mais le fou en 17 et pas mal placé il
faut mieux sortir il faut bien de sortir
dames 2 un coût plus ou moins d'attentes
de développement on lit les tours c'est
tout à fait classique fawcett rouach
donc ça c'est en fait un cas où les
bleus savent pas trop à droite sociale
c'est typiquement un coût qui prépare f4
c'est bien d'éviter toute possibilité
pour les noirs de protéger dauphin de
contre attaquer sur la diagonale à 7 g 1
mais c'est clairement pour jouer une
attaque avec f4 et f5 ou peut-être ça
qui était très sympa donc là c'est
l'heure on n'a pas mis une fois en 17
pour rien c'est pour jouer le coup b5
les noirs de toute façon ils doivent
chercher du contre je donc quand les
plantes jouent pas à quatre tours c'est
fou 17 et b5 tout à fait normal les cinq
menace évidemment stéphane b 4 puisque
sur camélia kath turquie a et prend des
cartes y allez prenez 4 et le gabriac
avait retraite emprise du fou 17 et si
lecavalier c3 doit revenir sur la case
des uns n'est pas bon il est pas beau il
ya même moche ouais donc ça ne va pas à
3 1 3 devant jijel et quatre en un petit
rock balkanique et maintenant le fameux
f4 qui avait été préparé par rouach
exactement merci c'est difficile pour
les noirs contre attaquer tout de suite
sur cette diagonale parce qu'elle
fouille 3 qui veillent donc c'est un
coup prophylactique à longue portée un
rush
oui en plus ça permet régulièrement dans
les variantes où le cavalier arrivants
gkp par exemple qu'on n'y a eu que 5 de
mettre le faut sur laquelle j'ai un
ouais donc c'est en fait ça libère
laquelle j'ai un don certain cap ici
maintenant la question c'est comment
attaquer les blancs puisque le plan de
blanc on le voit très clairement c'est
g4 g5 f5 ça arrive avec une attaque
inscriptions à utaka double tranchant
quand même parce que en général
quand on a leur miroir du même côté on
est visite à pousser ses propres pions
puisqu'on a fait peut-être un peu les
noirs mais on s'affaiblit aussi
dangereusement c'est vrai mais on prend
quand même une initiative assez forte
dans la mesure où dès qu'on chasse le
cavaliere 6 on le rappelle qu'en de
fouet contre 17
ça devient extrêmement pénible oui mais
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de cases à ces
dispositions il va être aussi bien sur
la case de 8 quand il faut le mettre en
8 c'est une cata donc maintenant se pose
le problème comment jouer une position
thématique de cécile ndash dorff quand
on les blancs n'ont pas empêché b5 les
tills en régie à b5 parra 3 comment
poursuivre l' attaque alors on ne peut
pas jouer à 5 pour joe des cas puisque
tu en bessin qui systématiquement en
prison il faut donc faire autre chose
voilà le tout la problématique de cette
position puisque le plan des blancs est
clair alors souvent souvent ce type de
position il ya le fou et 3 comme ça
c'est de d'essayer d'arriver à mettre le
cavalier c6 sur la case ces quatre
exactement il attaque le cavalier
l'attaquent b2 ça c'est un premier plan
mais le problème de ce plan stéphane
c'est que le fou va revenir très
calmement c'est un hommage ou et b2 b3
et on n'aura toujours pas d' attaque
donc c'est une possibilité qu'il faut
jamais négliger n est qu à venir c4
toujours vérifier si ces forts ou pas
fort en l'occurrence ça ne l'est pas
suffisamment et quand ça ne l'est pas
assez il faut envoyer des moyens
d'urgence parce que là il y a urgence et
donc le plan stéphane s'est
régulièrement que des quatre pions prend
des quatre pieds premier 4 donc on
affaiblit un petit peu nos structures
d'options puisque le pion à 6 va se
retrouver sous le feu de la tour on
l'est de la dame et de la dame
mais c'est pas grave puisque nous on va
obtenir deux colonnes b et c est notre
idée en fait dans ce genre de position
c'est de faire diversion éviter tout
simplement de serre matez donc c'est ce
que fait x 9 tours fc 8 et non pas tour
assez vite et n'ont pas toujours assez
vite ce qui semble bizarre puisque
finalement à tours à huit est toujours
quand même sous le feu du fou j'ai deux
oui donc on n'a pas envie de mettre la
torah 8 souvent assez vite mais étant
donné que plat l'on sait jouer b4 et
d'avoir les deux colonnes il fallait
jouer de rester une vitrine fouet froid
dans cette position pourquoi pas les
blancs continuent leurs attaques ils
auraient pu tenter g4 tout de suite mais
c'est en fait non est-ce que sur gk tout
de suite il y a le thématiques qu'elle
prend des quatre fous prend des cartes
est aussi inquiet de 5 qui cassent
complètement hors là une structure des
plombs blanc va être terrible à cycling
ne songer qu'à ses fans surtout il a
gagné plein jusqu'à ce que le food et
cette soirée c'est vrai faux f3 donc
maintenant tout rabais vite voilà on a
compris pourquoi on avait joué l'autre
tour ans et huit exactement là on veut
jouer très clairement des 4 et après
qu'elle ait b3 maintenant c'est l'heure
des 4b quatre pions prend bep cap
qu'elle prend b4 et là on reprend notre
souffle on regarde bien cette position
qu'est ce qu'on voit stéphane on voit
des menaces de partout qui est français
2 qui doit pouvoir menacer assez
rapidement sous peu qu'on a réussi avec
une fois de plus stocker et b3 on voit
également des saints qui peut arriver au
programme on voit le fou ce 17 pour
sortir ans et six en tout cas le passé
le fou de cases blanches des blancs le
faux f3 n'a plus aucune pièce à attaquer
exactement on plie tout a été libéré et
stéphane on voit bien quand même que les
tours font pression une pression grosse
pression du côté dames c'est vrai que
c'est délicat
les tours sont plutôt belle donc ici
très belle position pour ifs kof
la partie continue mais enfin c'est
plutôt pas mal c'est plutôt une réussite
on va regarder notre 4e 3e parti stefan
wey donc là c'était sur la tentative fou
aux trois à la caf 4 way donc on a vu la
première c'est qu'il essaie de donner
ces cas là on voit fou et 3,4 maintenant
on va voir une nouveauté la nouvelle
idée donc toujours un ordre de coûts
curieux puisque en fait avec le nageur
fonds n'arrivent pas trop les blanches
ou pas j'ai 3 contre la nasa offre en
général si on prend en 2006 et ses trois
des six
j'ai trois à six donc là en fait c'est
comme si on avait une hache dorff au
coude avant dans cette position là si
l'option était en à 6 au lieu de 1,6 et
1,7 au lieu de
du contraire et on joue g3 et on joue
aussi c'est comme si on allait jouer
aussi ça se fout g2 maintenant donc là
on voit tout de suite que les plans et
b52 c'est toujours extrêmement dangereux
comme d'habitude le cavalier des fois on
hésite à le sortir en 17
mais là on veut absolument le maître ans
et 6 pour contrôler cette diagonale donc
d'homme c'est cet homme n'est pas tout
de suite tombé après petit rock qu'elle
nécessite maintenant hélas un essai
extrêmement direct stéphane cavaliers
pros québec car il pointe quelques pas
vraiment faire plus directe tout à fait
alors la dame prend se heurte à eux cinq
voiliers qui gagne un pion avec fougue
et 2 se réveillant sur la dame qui
gagnent un bon pion central qui fait
très très mal qui fait très mal
donc on prend ces sites c'était un
prince et six et maintenant cavalier à 4
comme il ya 14 ça permet de jouer ces
quatre voilà et en même temps sa menace
fou ou trois avec invasion des
classements avec en tout cas pression
sur laquelle ce bâtiment là mais me des
menaces dans cette position il faut il
faut bien faire quelque chose il faut
choisir si on met le fou en b 717 ya le
choix
mais on préfère le mettre sur le kst 17
pour une raison très simple c'est que la
caisse 17 appartient aux quais relief 6
c'est ce cavalier là qui va venir là
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus sur
cette structure de pions puisqu'elle est
quand même très complexe au départ après
keziah 4,7 et femmes il faut choisir
entre eux bon les blancs vont jouer ses
cartes ça c'est sûr il faudra choisir
entre ces 5 ou 1 5 mais pas les deux
ouais bah oui parce que les deux
s'affaiblit la case des 5
voilà c'est jamais très bon mais c'est
vrai que c'est simple avantage c'est que
ça bouge chez les possibilités poule 3
oui et ça libérera le fourbe et 7
si on vous dit si on joue ces 5 de toute
façon ici on va vous montrer les deux
possibilités parce que les deux
possibilités se valent donc on va
commencer par regarder celle là fougue
et cette c4 c5
voilà libère avec les 17 sur le yart
contre attaque champions 4 tout
simplement menacé
voilà ça sera ouverte c'est très logique
hein on attaque le pion aux 4 le
cavalier revient en c3 puisque quand on
a joué ses 5 il n'a strictement rien à
faire à quatre mois c'est normal
maintenant on sort nos pièces fou au 7
mai les blancs jouer actifs pour une
raison très simple stéphane c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autre plan
c'est dire que le plan des noirs on le
voit très bien c'est tout est flou ces
sites
enfin petit rock évidemment m'être
peut-être une tour en 2 8 pouces et 6 et
poussé le pion à 5 à 4 l'attaqué b2c un
plan vraiment classique wii et un cap
des 3 ça va miner la phalange des pions
blancs
tout à fait on réattaque qui vont
attaquer sur la colonne mais on va faire
valoir votre contre je donc les blancs
jouent f4 avec attac une tente
d'attaquer
donc là on n'a pas toujours à chaum
parce que le pilote qui ont ces scènes
de toute façon à empêcher les noirs de
de faire un quelconque échec sur la
diagonale est ici cavaliers 17
c'est un coup d'évacuation tranquille on
veut pas laisser le club nîmois 6 on le
remet sur la case 17
bon ça c'est possible l'idée s'est
régulièrement de faux et 6 ça me
rappelle d'ailleurs une variante je
crois qu'on l'a montré dans la leçon une
vente comme ça où l'on joué avec vous et
si je sais plus avec elle c'était avoir
toujours dans la sienne d'altorf
évidemment fouet trois petit rock tient
tranquille g4 donc les blancs attaque
ils attaquent mais là y'a rien à
attaquer puisque cavaliers partie le
cavalier partie ici c'est une attaque un
petit peu dans le vide voilà ici les
doigts on joue un coup un peu
responsables ils sont je le fous et 6
alors je ne sais pas trop cissokho est
bon en tout cas moi j'aurais plutôt
préconisé de jouer simplement fous ces
six c6 avec le plan à 5 à 4 tours bénite
plan tout à fait classique
oui c'est vrai qu'il faut être si ce bon
faut aussi sa menace peut-être font
prendre qu'à elle et ses trois pour
boyer les pions blancs et par contre ça
peut ça peut être sous le feu de g4 g5
c'est le problème donc disons que la
partie a mal tourné pour les noirs après
x 6 mai c'est dans cette position que je
voulais tout simplement vous recommander
de jouer le coup normal fous ces six à
quatre à cinq tours b 8 à 4 avec je
pense une très belle position pour les
noirs voilà donc ce troisième exemple
nous allons passer au dernier exemple
qui est une partie entre deux très fort
joueur stéphane puisqu'il s'agit de yves
en dessous qui a les blancs et kazim
janos qu'ils allaient noire alors qu'est
une gêne au fond rappel il est n'est pas
fou il est où ce bec liés aux becs
les quasars en fait donc à zap et le
team usa 9 il a été champion du monde
juniors non non non non mais on veut
convier dans le top 10 mondial
ouais il a plus de 2700 points elo donc
c'est un extrêmement forts joueurs
vivent de choc évidemment ne présente
plus le joueur le plus fou de la planète
qui est complètement mieux pas fous ils
peuvent fouiller les dix ont différents
il ya différents eux quatre ces cinq
cavaliers f3 de 6 donc encore un ordre
de coûts alternatif des quatre petits
enfants des quatre pieds pour des quatre
caisses et si ce qui est ces trois dames
c'est 7
j'ai trois à six fours et 2006 deux
tireurs des six
on y est c'est encore notre position
donc on a vu les toutes les tentatives
pour 1 100 kg co2 ouais l'idée de jouer
ses quatre pattes c'est pas très fort
nous faut trois on a vu fouet trois donc
sur flu et 3 ont réagi normalement on
fait fou 17 fawcett et b5 avec ensuite
sur a3 b4 tout à fait logique
ça c'est une autre possibilité on a vu
également dans la partie précédente qui
est prince et six sur comment reprendre
youtube et est ensuite tombé le fond en
on n'est pas obligé que si lemaitre 17
comme on va le voir dans cette partie et
là nous voyons le couteau à un coût de
renforcement qui menace régulièrement
stéphane découper le cahier des cinq
week avec des scènes puisque sur qui on
prend on peut faire plein de prendre des
5 avec échelle comprendre cinq échecs
est sûr qu avait lieu cet énorme des
problèmes pour sortir leur pièce c'est
un sacrifice de pièces qui arrivent
régulièrement il faut s'en méfier mais
en tout cas pour l'instant il ya fou 17
voilà 17 qui est des cinq de toute
évidence ne marche pas pour le moment et
là quel point ces six là
stéphane c'est un problème ça me prend
pour reprendre du fou ça leur reprendre
du feu n'a pas l'air mauvais ça a pas
l'air mauvais ne reprend du fou et
pourtant c'est sa tête et jouer je pense
à cause de qualité 5
oui parce que là on peut plus on peut
pas jouer tous ces six ans le set
exaspéré chèque
c'est le problème on n'a pas le droit
donc on ne peut pas prendre du fou à
cause de qui est des cinq c'est toute
l'idée donc on reproduction b et les
blancs ont réussi par leur ordre de
coups un peu curieux à nous placer notre
fou sur la case 17 au lieu de ça change
beaucoup de choses hein tout à fait
puisque maintenant on a plus qu'à et 17
et ainsi de suite dans toute la casim
geof a trouvé un moyen très original de
jouer dans cette position sur cavani à 4
il joue tourbe et vite
ouais donc c'est assez
les contrôles de la case des six baies 3
maintenant c'est normal il joue avec eux
cinq cette fois ci donc en fait il faut
il faut il faut bien faire attention à
ce qui se passe là c'est un autre plan
différent il nous a forcé avec le fois
en 17
donc on joue avec le couple on a eu cinq
voile avantage c'est que ça tue le g2
satuc complètement fou j'ai ensuite on
va sortir avec fawcett petit rock enfin
après ça va être énorme
la partie a poursuivi part d'amd 3 à 5
le pire étant aux prises les pions et et
en plus il est bien plus ça donne la
classe b 4 qui peut être utile qui est
très utile dacca ce mec est fou des deux
fosses est normal là pour l'instant
kazim janov il voit pas trop où ils vont
tous venir alors ils vendent tout fait
ces quatre petit rock
maintenant il ya eu torah c'est un art
menace probablement ces cinq exactement
mais c'est là justement qu'il faut pas
avoir peur
il a joué tous rêvent des beats avec
donc une idée très simple dans cette
position son prochain poussette vous
aussi ce après sur ses seins qui aura
systématiquement des 5
donc ça a pas de problème il faut juste
vérifier dans cette position que c'est
ça ne marche pas et c'est ce qu'il a
fait donc on va récapitule expression
quart numéro un
les plantes jouent pas c'est 5 ouais
donc dans ce cas le prochain point noir
c'est fou aux six ans huit cahiers 17
on revient avec le cavalier ou aux
menaces des 5
ouais on menace de s'étendre aussi c'est
peut-être tout simplement deux des cinq
on peut je me fous et fuite aussi bref
y'a pas de problème le cap critique
stéphane c'est comme tu l'as dit ces
cinq voiliers parce que ça casse la
structure des pions noirs si on prend
ces 5
ça a l'air très mauvais pour les noirs
puisque le pion c6 va se retrouver sous
le feu de la torcéen devait être arriéré
donc non défendu et
probablement il faudra prendre le cas
rien c'est 5 avec le foot qui récupère
un fou donc et pas une bonne nouvelle
dans cette position donc il est joué
plus on prend ces cinq qu'elle prend ses
5 es fou g4 alors qu'est ce qui se passe
en fait là ils jouent pour l'activité et
le dynamisme et c'est là qu'on va voir
justement que sur ce coup c'est simple
et noir ont tellement bien placé seul
leur pièce que malgré tous les
inconvénients que tu as cité c'était
aller qui ont isolé
ouais lefort cavaliers way la tour sur
la colonne c'est qu'ils visent la dame
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses les
noirs ont suffisamment de jeu mais à une
fourchette en racisme pour l'instant la
dame blanche est attaquée dame ne s'est
attaqué par leur éclatement faut faire
attention donc dame de 3 pouces et 8
bon pour l'instant sa valeur au texte
empêchent qu'un média 6 ans pêche qui
avait dit à 6 et menaces tour des cats
stéphane il veut rentrer sont sur ces
cases la wii donkey les tours ces deux
tours des quatre tours au c1 ils vont
tous qu'un style typique wimy mais la
solution c'est s'il a raison c'est la
faiblesse maintenant il ya une dame des
beats way fou un tour b 5 on va
s'arrêter là pour cette partie parce que
ça devient très compliqué mais en tout
cas c'est serré quand même là c'est
équilibre les noirs ont suffisamment de
jeu contrôle très bien la colonne des
s'équilibre et les blancs menace
systématiquement par le plan c 6 mais ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que le fujian où
est hors jeu
le projet de hors-jeu la colonne des
appartient au noir exactement autre
phénomène très important devra sortir le
cavalier csn pour attaquer ses six et
dans ce cas là un coup comme fou
bessette ou de 17,6 à vous aussi vous
donc pour protéger ses six peut-être à
huy l'info bessette permet de de tenir à
distance les tours parce qu'on va pas
sacrifier une tour contre donc voilà
donc on a vu plein de possibilités
stéphane donc dans tous les cas c'est
toujours les plans classique on sort les
pièces en rock on joue b5 dès qu'on peut
si les blancs défendre par trois ans
joue b 4 6 1 et o2 maroc si on sort les
pièces et on veut jouer des 5
donc pour résumer ce système avec g3
n'est pas spécialement dangereux puisque
régulièrement le fou se retrouve hors
jeu c'est quand même le problème
principal
et passifs donc on vous donne rendez
vous donc les gens vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette émission on vous donne
rendez vous très prochainement
stéphane donc et bien à bientôt bientôt
mais enfin
m